hi everyone uh my my name is Daniel I'm
a software engineer at posit and today
I'm going to talk about what is near in
the torch
ecosystem but first uh what exactly is
torch so torch is a port of P torch for
art and it's essentially a scientific
Computing Library providing a consistent
API for
uh uh Computing on arrays and matrices
but it it has a strong uh support for
Hardware acceleration so you can run
these computations on your GPU to make
them much faster and it also has support
a buing uh uh automatic differentiation
system uh um in the package so so it's
it can be used for statistical and deep
learning mod uh modeling
uh it it is also a deep learning uh
framework so it it implements most of
the building blocks uh of modern deep
learning models such as layers and
optimizers but torch is a big project
and just uh like a big city it's hard to
find your way around it when you are
getting started and we hope this is much
better now because we have we recently
announced the Deep learning and
scientific Computing with ar torch book
this book was written by siget K my
colleague at posit and it is available
for free online or you can buy from CRC
press and it covers the basics of deep
learning as well as really implementing
the models in in torch
NR uh but still navigating in in large
cities is hard and it's much easier if
if you have the
metro and that's what loose is for torch
so loose abstracts away much of uh the
boiler plate code that you need to write
when training uh deep learning models
with torch and it has uh its API is
inspired by fast Ai and caras which are
successful libraries in in
Python and so it's still very flexible
and extensible with callbacks Matrix and
Etc so with lose you write your model
exactly the same way you would write
when using raw TCH but instead of uh
manually handling a lot of details such
as like moving the model to the correct
device or uh manually iterating over
your data you let loose do every
everything for you so your code is
cleaner and it's it's also much less
error prone
but sometimes you don't want to learn
all the details and everything and you
can pick a taxi and that's what Tabet
and Brule help in
torch uh they are actually uh just T
tidy models extensions powered by torch
that you can call with single liners
like this uh to train uh neural network
models on table
data and they can also be used your
usual tidy models workflows uh and V
deployments and
Etc and finally it's nice to talk with
the local community so we recently
announced hugging face
Integrations so uh we have the talk
package and agf
hub uh with HF Hub you can download uh
uh large models hosted in the hugging
face hub for example if you were in the
in Jeremy's Howard talk uh where he
downloaded a Lama model in into python
you can do this in R using H fhub and
then load the model we into R and talk
can be used to use the exact same
pre-processing pipelines as
in as in as they use when training the
model so you get the exact same results
so in theory like you can uh run these
models
uh uh directly in in in art without even
having a python uh in
installation and thank you very much uh
next week we'll be teaching torch uh in
the workshops for Ukraine project and
it's a nice opportunity if you want to
learn more about torch and get started
thank you